foreign
s us up next and he is in Columbia South
Carolina Jason welcome to the show
ah it's actually taking my call
appreciate it absolutely what's going on
um uh my question is I was trying to put
my baby steps in order and I was
listening on my debt and um so I put my
wife and mine together in there and my
question was when I got to the interest
rates you got to say interest rate
doesn't matter but it seemed like that'd
be because I have I have balances that
are similar like a four thousand dollar
one and a six thousand dollar credit
card and So based off of your methods I
would say off the four thousand dollar
one first but it has like 13 uh interest
on it and the six thousand dollar one
has like 24 interest on it so it seems
like if I was to ignore the six thousand
and pay the four thousand one I'd be
getting a lot of interest racked up on
the six thousand dollars so I'm just
kind of curious as to why interest rate
doesn't matter well the reason that we
teach that is because a lot of times
when you're getting out of debt it's not
just about the math part of it it's the
behavioral part that's also a huge part
of the equation that many times gets
left out right so we have found uh over
the years that the debt snowball method
is actually the most proven way to pay
off debt which is listing them from
smallest to largest Harvard even did a
study about it that showed that when you
get those small wins because if you
really think about it a lot of times the
debt that has the lowest interest
usually is some of the biggest debt that
we have right so anyway it's great to
listen from lowest to smallest by
balance and then you're getting those
small wins quickly and the more that you
get wins the more that you actually
believe that you can do it and you stay
motivated and through the Long Haul we
actually see more people paying off debt
through completion so that's the way
that we that's the reason that we opt
for the debt snowball over another
method which what you're saying would be
the debt Avalanche method
does that kind of make sense and we
found Jason all this personal finance
stuff it's really Behavior it's 80
Behavior it's only 20 head knowledge and
when you knock out that smallest debt it
actually gives you this little thing
called hope that motivates you to get
the next debt and by the way it freed up
a payment for you to apply to that next
debt on top of all the margin and all of
a sudden you see some light at the end
of the tunnel and so that is the purpose
of the debt snowball it's to create
momentum and so you're right on paper if
you can do the Avalanche method and do
it perfectly then go for it but the
truth is if you had that kind of
discipline then we wouldn't have been in
debt in the first place
right I understand yeah and I I have
never had this discipline I've been me
either brother that's why I I just
submitted to this other guy's plan
because I was like well he's got money
and I don't so let's see if his plan
works I know that's right I did the same
thing man I had 4 000 in credit card
debt I had 36 000 in student loans and
they were all split up into a bunch of
loans and instead of doing debt
consolidation and trying to be fancy and
move the debt around and pay off the
highest interest first I just went I'm
just going to start attacking these from
smallest to largest regardless of the
interest rate and man in 18 to 24 months
that's the average time it takes for
people to get completely debt free how
much debt do you have
uh total including Vehicles about right
about 50 000. and what's your household
income
about a hundred thousand okay cool
that's about normal for people to have
half of their income tied up in debt and
that means you can pay this thing off
you're making 100K how quickly do you
think you'll pay off this 50 doing uh
the baby steps with gazelle intensity
right I mean two years from now your
life is going to look totally different
yeah we're talking 18 months right
right
so we can do this thing but it starts
with going all right I'm just going to
go all in on this instead of argue with
myself of why I'm going to do it a
different way or tweak it I'm telling
you go all in for just try it for six
months and see the progress you're
making
and it gets addictive
all right I appreciate it yeah man
thanks so much for the call it's a good
conversation and it's you're not the
first to to ask that question and
truthfully for a lot of people there's
not a great answer because it's hard to
argue with math it is but it's also hard
to argue with hundreds of thousands
millions of people who have done this
stuff and you're like oh but they're
debt free and I'm not so
there's the pudding there it is and my
thing is like when I think about high
interest debt versus low interest debt I
mean usually the stuff with the the
smallest interest is your biggest debt
you know if you're thinking about
student loans that's like the single
percentage stuff usually your car
a mortgage if you list that stuff first
by interest rate you're gonna it's gonna
take you forever you're going to lose
motivation if I listed my first debt by
interest rate I would have had to pay
off ninety thousand dollars in one shot
instead of a 200 Little Store card that
I had it doesn't you know yeah you got
to go by motivation motivation is what
keeps you going and I like you know when
you see that interest rack up it makes
you angry and so I'm okay with that
because anger is the fuel you need to
get to debt Freedom it always starts
with anger if you're not angry and
you're comfortable with your situation
and you're happy sitting in your pile of
debt then you're not going to change but
when you start looking at how much
you're giving to lenders every month
through your payments and through
interest instead of Building Wealth for
your family
now you want to punch through a wall you
want to run through the wall like the
Kool-Aid man once you see those numbers
and so I want you to be angry because
that tells me you're ready to actually
change once and for all and change your
family tree and change your legacy so
that that is another reason on top of
freeing up payments faster and feeling
the progress I want you to have a little
bit of pain because we have gotten way
too comfortable as a society Americans
have been sitting in their debt in
comfort in la la land wondering why they
can't build wealth blaming the economy
in the White House and inflation and
it's the egg prices now oh God and are
we going to tell the day your payments
are the reason you're broke it's not the
egg prices so stop complaining about the
egg prices and start looking in the
mirror and saying that's the real
problem not eggs being three dollars
more than they were six months ago and
that's right so anywhile you got me all
riled up George I'm not adding anything
to that I'm just gonna sit here and
imagine you running through a wall